in the 2014 U.S chess championships the
most exciting thing that could have
happened did happen we moved from round
robin to playoffs for the U.S
Championship a draw between Alexander
Lenderman and verucia nicobian opened
the door for a three-way tie as
defending Champion gotta kamski won his
game to join the party
for the women Irena crush and Anna
zaponsky could only draw their games so
in the wings Tate abrahamian won her
game to catch up
and like the men the women are now in a
three-way time
Armageddon is upon us in St Louis
foreign
hello and welcome to the 2014 U.S chess
championships and U.S women's chess
championships now in playoff in St Louis
the capital of South America we are
right across the street from the World
Chess Hall of Fame at the beautiful St
Louis chess club where Gary Casper have
called the nicest chess club in the
world and we have one of the most
exciting finalities that I've ever
witnessed in the U.S championship
absolutely showdown in St Louis today
now we see our just four players have
showed up so far because got a chance to
me and Irina crash have been seated into
the finals due to Superior tie breaks so
they're chilling meanwhile I always see
abrahamian already here Linderman here
it is going to be a real thrilling day
yeah and what they're doing for the
Armageddon gen is it's 45 minutes for
the white player and the players are
bidding uh on the minutes for the black
player and the black player will have
draw odds in the Armageddon matches
that's right and this year unlike
previous years there are no increments
so it is going to be thrilling indeed
let's take a look and see how it's going
down in the U.S Chess Championship
we've got a three-way tie at the top
with version of kobian and Alexander
Lenderman they're contesting that
Armageddon match for the right to play
gotta kamski coincidentally he's also
the defending Champion but really it was
his Superior tie breaks with Dave in
that scene
and they're actually going to start in
that second match in the final not with
an Armageddon but rather a two-game
rapid so we're here for a while guys
it's gonna be fun meanwhile zitotsky and
avrahamian same situation winner gets
the right to play Irina crash in a rapid
match
absolutely can't wait yesterday was one
of the most exciting days of tests I've
ever seen and
I might just tap it Maurice Ashley what
do you think
indeed a very exciting day here at the
championship six players vying for two
titles incredible situation the rules
even the rules the players had to study
well let's take a look we have seed
number two and seed number three playing
the winner is going to play seed number
one who had the superior tie breaks in
the head-to-head matchup the two-game
rapid match will decide the championship
if they're tied they'll move on to a
final Armageddon game to see who wins it
all well if you're confused so were the
players some of them did not know the
rules at all yesterday I had to explain
them to Anna zatonski
what are your thoughts going into
tomorrow's matchup you have to play Tata
first first of all with that matchup you
played her into you played her two years
ago for the Championships what do you
think about that game okay I'm still
thinking about my previous game which I
just finished I didn't know I had I have
to play tattoo for first and uh I
thought my burger is better but I'm not
sure maybe I'm wrong it's not it's not a
burger type it's head-to-head
so and um so okay I need to I need to
read how like we are playing with time
control and how many games so you don't
know the rules of the tie break no no
but a three-way
three which I break I don't know the
three-way tiebreak has you and I forgot
last year I didn't play Ty bricks I'm
not sure well you have to play an
Armageddon game against Tate
yes right away right away were you a bit
to see who gets black and black has draw
odds so that's the situation before you
go and play Arena
imagine being unclear about the rules
just several hours before you have to
play one of the most important games of
your life followed by one of the most
important matches of your life well I'm
sure she's clear on it now she defeated
Tate abrahamian in their individual
matchup in this tournament so she should
feel confident going into this the
championship round of the playoffs
incredible situation we're all excited
it should be one Epic day at the
Championships guys
and let's go upstairs where executive
director at the St Louis chess club also
an Arbiter Tony Rich will fill us in on
the bids and who gets black and who gets
draws exactly
welcome everyone to the
closing uh I'm sorry excuse me welcome
everyone to the playoffs for the 2014
U.S championship in 2014 U.S Women's
Championship I'm Tony Rich the organizer
of the events and I'm joined here today
by four out of these six players who are
tied for first in their respective
events on my left we have Anna zatonski
and tatev abrahamian on my right virus
nicobian and Alex Lenderman moments ago
the players bid the amounts of time with
which they were willing to begin their
Armageddon game in order to choose their
color now an Armageddon game is one in
which the player with the black pieces
has draw odds so it's a very important
process
our Women's Championship competitors
have bid their times and the clock times
have been set white who will be Anna
zatonski who will have 45 minutes and
black Tate of abrahamian will have 29
minutes and
45 seconds
in the U.S Championship section Baruch
nicobian has been
29 minutes and 57 seconds to Alex
Linderman's
33 minutes therefore VAR will have the
black pieces and he will have draw odds
Alex will have a full 45 minutes in the
white pieces the games will begin in
just a moment so Stand By and enjoy
all right so varuja nikobi and entity of
abrahamian both getting the black pieces
and draw odds and we're going to confirm
with you the bids in a minute because uh
oh actually I I see them right here for
original clothing with 29 minutes and 57
seconds and talked about rahamian with
29 minutes and 45 seconds so very
similar winning bids right now in U.S
Chess Championship history you might
know that the bids have been
historically lower of course the
system's only been around for a little
while and shout out to Greg Jihadi who
helped come up with some of the ideas
here wonderful and uh last year it was
actually 19 minutes and 20 minutes but
there was a key difference there there
was a five second increment today there
will be no increment and that's why we
see these larger bids exactly a little
bit higher yeah but even kind of higher
than you would expect because if you
think about it a 60 move game
well I was thinking that 30 minutes was
somehow the right uh figure and so this
29 57 29 45 kind of just as right in
what did our audience think about that
well yesterday we were asked our
audience uh to tell us what they might
have been did they come in the majority
above 30 or the majority below 30. I'll
check on that but you can continue to
let us know what you they're using
remember these are rapid games and
there's only two of them so it's going
to get pretty hot in the next hour but
we are going to have some time to uh
take your your thoughts and questions as
well so you're about to get started
let's get some thoughts from Maurice on
these bids the winning bids do you think
they were good bids
I think there were predictable bids and
it's time for a prediction I'm going to
give mine I think that this was a very
good bid for a Cobian he wants to be the
with the black pieces he's very solid
yesterday I said it so I'm not going to
vary from that now as much as I love the
way Linderman has played in this
competition I think that with the black
pieces Jacobian should be able to hold
the draw I don't expect to see him win
the game it should be a draw on his side
but again Linderman has been playing
some really good chess we'll see if he
can go for it in this game and win and
on the women's side you've got to think
that satonski is going to pull this off
she has been a fighter throughout the
competition and there is no increment at
all so that 29 minutes is really going
to play against abrahamian so I'm
predicting a win for zatonski in this
game and see her move on but again a
brilliant Blitz player in Tate
abrahamian with the black pieces so she
seems confident and they're ready to go
yeah so what's your guess on this one
ah so you like you like black um by the
way honest
five minutes
since the movie's coming on now so that
means that strategically that's not so
wise because that means that have
thought to have a bed bid like 40. right
he would have just gotten black and draw
a lot then only five minute deficit so a
bit of a strange bid there but uh
perhaps uh Anna really likes what she
prepared with the white pieces
remember she defeated tatev in the first
game that their head-to-head matchup
with the white pieces so clearly she
wants to have that color again and the
time Advantage he feels is to her favor
and
I think is is here it looks like we've
got a ninja Indian
um
Anna playing pretty quickly Queen C2
castles and I didn't see
the next move after Queen C2
looks like E4 actually Queen C2 castles
E4 D5 this is an exceptionally sharp
line
um
in this line the nimzo Indian this E4
move
and I think the main lines go E5
94 Bishop D3 C5 knighty2 I don't know
which lady has more experience in this
line but it's really important because
it's such a complicated
sharp variation
well we saw Anna playing the names
earlier in the tournament from the white
side right but remember how long she
took against Katya yesterday that even
though she was very familiar with the
opening she played it very slowly as
white and that was the similar line but
with 4d5 well that was with A3 not E4
oh I see so it was the same line really
yeah it was so it was with A3 and then
after Bishop Bishop takes C3 Queen C3 D5
here exactly okay yeah and today she's
gone for E to E4 D5 E5 and again there
there's been some wild wild games in
this line
um
play and let's see just check with our
other
games game oops copy three ah
interestingly Anna did not play the
theoretical move Bishop D3 she played A3
Bishop takes C3 check B take C3 now
after C5 I always thought that this
position was okay for black
um
just
immediately counter-attacking the center
let's see the other game
oh see what's going on in verucian's
game okay let's just go from the take
we'll take it from the top uh Linderman
with the English opening C4 E5 G3 Bishop
G2 Knight F6 93 Bishop C5
um I kind of call this the Anatoly
karpov system
black just bring post his Bishop outside
of his Pawn structure doesn't play for
King side fee and Shadow but wants to
play D7 D6 when the bishop is outside of
the Central Pawn structure E3 castles A3
all of these moves have been seen
in fact in a U.S championship game that
I had with Alexander shabala of shibalov
had black in this particular line B4
basically white could play for D4 but
after Bishop drops back to A7 is this
constant nagging pressure against this
Pawn on D4 and white does not want to
play The Deep move D5 because after the
Knight Retreats the bishop is blocked
that's why Alex went for a flank
expansion with the move B2 B4 Bishop
drop back Bishop D2 Rook B8
hmm interesting setup by Jacobian here I
think he envisions playing Bishop D7
and moving his Knight over to the king
site
all to play for of course in this battle
and let me just see if we're up to date
wrong one
in the other game yeah yeah so after the
move Rook B8
uh Linderman ended up playing D4 now
it's a little different uh now with the
pawns on B4 and D4 white can play for
the move C5 shutting out this bishop on
A7
see how it continued takes and
Alex Slenderman to play we're expecting
him to recapture with his Pawn on D4
then the variation might continue the
game I mean might continue something
like Bishop G4 H3 Bishop back to F5 and
at some point white wants to
block this bishop on A7 keep it out of
the game for as long as possible with
the move C4 C5
to your liking Letterman's opening so
far
yes I prefer White
definitely
so far so good
and wrong game
there we go so indeed we did see this
move C5 by
that you have C5 Bishop came to D3 Queen
A5
putting pressure
on this diagonal and more specifically
at the moment this Pawn on C3
on a played Knight E2 and black to play
now
we could see the move Pawn takes D4 and
of course we're not permitted to
recapture thanks to the
um
pin on the diagonal takes takes castles
this is a little weird I don't exactly
see White's compensation here I might
just simply capture this Pawn oh there
it is pardon me there's F2 F3 well it's
not so clear to you Jen queen queen C5
check that's gonna get messy
maybe
not that favorable for white no white
might have to play a move like Knight G3
but these are pawns over here uh very
sharp uh struggle occurring here in this
line I wonder how deeply Anna has
prepared her for this variation because
lots of imbalances going on here
and uh
the
uh sorry yeah we did see by the way uh
recaptured by Lenderman with his Pawn as
expected I thought VAR was going to play
Bishop G4 and just provoke white to
weaken his King his position a little
bit with the move H2 H3 instead Bishop
F5 came at once and we see now we see
this move C4 C5 so a severe problem for
black at the moment how is he going to
bring this bishop on A7 into play from
White's point of view White's play is
absolutely As Natural as a baby smile he
wants to play Knight E2 to F4 followed
by Knight C3 to D5 taking up dominating
hosts in the center and again and again
and again we're going to see this
throughout the game how is black going
to deal with his uh Bishop on A7 which
is completely hemmed in by White's Pawns
all right um Maurice do you have
anything for us what do you think about
these positions
I think they're rich they're interesting
it seems like something is going to
happen that's decisive in these games
you look at these openings I can't
imagine that they expected exactly this
line of play for both sides so they are
now in my opinion they're winging it
they're just trying to solve problems
from move to move their Grandmaster
instincts coming out and just playing
serious chess that's it you know this is
interesting because they have to switch
from playing classic chess slower time
control to suddenly rapid chess that
transition is not easy to do all the
time but no doubt these players
considered it they made sure they knew
the one thing they could not do is be
down on the clock quick decisions
instinctive responses not perfect moves
just best move you see right now and
they're battling
guys thank you Maurice
well again uh the sharpest game uh is
between Anna and abrahamian
I'm looking at this position Jen and I'm
thinking about the move F2 F3 for white
a little bit of a dangerous move it's a
two Pawn sacrifice for the moment
and it could very easily be a peace
sacrifice after a move light Bishop
takes H7 check King h8 now I don't like
the fact that the this queen on A5
uh has a discovered discover check but
Black's King also also has issues
um after the move Bishop D2 I was just
thinking about the peace sacrifice that
might result from G7 G6
Bishop takes G6 F takes G6 Queen takes
G6 and this is a wild Affair white is
set up for a Perpetual check but as we
know that will lose her the match so
white had better hope that in this case
she'll be able to do a to bring more
pieces very quickly into the attack
very unclear very uh sharp position I
I'm hesitant to say whether this is good
for white or not yeah so we backed up
one move there sure wondering
just to look at could you play Knight
takes D4 in this position yes instead
and not exactly maybe it looks like
you're going to win the night back right
and you'll be up a pawn
you're right absolutely right Knight
takes D4 would be a much better move
than capturing on G6 that is ultra sharp
I don't think that abrahamian wants to
go for this position uh this looks very
dangerous for black even if she's alive
uh she's definitely losing the Knight on
C3 although they might I don't know
trade-off pieces with Bishop F5 and hope
for Queen C3 to trade queens that might
be an option for her
she's down a pawn but I like her
position a lot yeah well I like white in
this case because of the extra Pawn for
sure but a real nice majority as well so
we're not going to see that line uh from
black let's just see once again
F3 was indeed played and Knight to C5
was played F3 Knight to C5 not going for
Knight C3 so this really does encourage
white to to play Bishop takes H7 check
King over into the corner and now we
have it now we really have an important
decision to make
are we worried about our Bishop on H7
getting trapped
um after the move
G7 G6
the problem is that move also creates a
threat D3 doesn't it yes after G6 there
is indeed a D2 D3 kind of pretty much
forces us to go in for that Bishop takes
G6 I just don't know like for example we
could play a move like H4 here
that is a weird move oh and then you but
after G6 of course you have to sacrifice
exactly to avoid the D3 exactly so I
think well here this is what I where I
was going with this one jet G7 G6 H5
D3 Queen D2 and check this out lots of
weaknesses over here on blacks dark
squares and white is just dreaming of an
opportunity of playing H5 takes G6
getting her Rook into the game and
attacking Black's King so some slash and
burn tactics early here by Anna and it
it all starts with this bishop takes H7
check
she did it
Anna you've got a light you've got a
light white here I mean white is better
developed well maybe not better
developed the wrong way to put it
because the king is still in the middle
but she dreamed about having an
aggressive position and now she has it
right out of the opening very unbalanced
Anything could happen here she's just
going for it we play she didn't play
your line she just castled looking
confident that she uh is not losing a
piece with castles G6 she's signaling as
I think her intention to sacrifice and
go for it with aggressive piece play so
she's going for it right here a wild
position I don't think this is ending in
a draw nobody's winning this game but it
is a shame for white that she doesn't
have that Perpetual on hand because
Perpetual is tantamount to losing
exactly yes that is absolutely the case
you gotta take you got to take what you
can get though right right prepare
whatever but it's made into her mind
right now it's King side attack uh I
don't think she she came to the board
thinking prepared anyway oh absolutely
white streaming of uh playing moves like
Bishop G5 to F6 checks they might come
to F4 it's a moment as well so we're
looking at Bishop F5 more or less as a
forcing move getting your queen uh
attacking the queen getting your Bishop
over there but after Knight takes D4
you know what I'd rather be a piece down
here than having to to try and defend
this position and navigate by the way
yeah navigate all the dangers that are
lurking and including the obvious Knight
takes F5 followed by Queen G6 check
picking up that rook in case of Rook
takes
um by the way yes if you need to go back
again those lines are so rich we just
throw ideas out right here back up there
what if you play Pawn takes Pawn First
forcing the Knight to move somewhere
random right right and then take on GC
where's the Knight going to go I would
guess E6 going to the king side I'll
grab the pawn now you're doing a bishop
F5 anymore Queen is safe on that side
the attack is not the same but uh F4 F4
F5 could happen here right
yeah and what's the white sure picked up
a lot of Pawns already it's a bishop H6
right now
um Bishop even Bishop G5 is possible
with the bishop F6 plan I'll take white
any day of the week here exactly
certainly in a rapid game oh definitely
and especially because Black's pieces on
the queen side are still sleeping yeah I
think Bishop G5 was better in that
position actually 75 with that way you
can always throw in a a queen 86 check
if you're attacked followed by followed
by Bishop F6 right and then F4 and Bloom
boom boom exactly all right well we are
going to take a quick break because I
don't think anybody can actually hear us
lip reading so we'll be right back
properly hello and welcome back to the
2014 U.S chess championships looks like
so many of you are trying to tune in and
we have sound I hope and have sound to
recap we've got drawds here for both
abrahamian and a Cobian they both bid
around the same exact time 29 45 and 29
55.
sobrahamian getting attacked by Anna
zatonski but she does have draw odds in
her pocket but hey you guys were loving
this position for Wyatt you thought the
pieces were just leaping into action and
that this was going to be very difficult
to defend in the time situation even
though she has drawlags precisely we
were we were looking at a line with G7
G6 and both Maurice and I were very uh
happy to have the white position in this
line of play we don't think the move G7
G6 is in fact playable we just think
that that would be losing of course we
all like to grab pieces but not at such
a great cost or risk to our King
with and since G7 G6 is really looking
like a bad move for black
I think tatyf is going to have to settle
for D4 take C3 and just live with the
fact that her King is going to be
exposed for the rest of the game
and we do have a couple of extra moves
in so after unfortunate castles there
was D takes C3 right and then Knight
takes C3 by Anna and Bishop to E6 is on
the board all right
so pawns are technically even but white
is snapped up that very important
protective Pawn on ah7 so what do you
make of this what do you well I'm
looking immediately of course at the
move F4 because I my my gut reaction my
knee-jerk reaction is I would want to
get rid of this bishop on E6 because of
the threat of F5 and I would be going
all out again and Anna really has no
choice she's really got to go uh
ballistic over here on the king side
with moves like this or you could you
could preface it with just uh so it
looks like after King takes H7 just
Queen takes F5 King G8 and we've got our
F6 ready Rover Checkmate coming up here
96.
you're coming the other way for us Queen
G4 check and King H7 Queen H5 and now
Checkmate on another Square exactly 20
push-ups
that's not a back rank mate yeah it's
true there's a very critical move in
this position that the engine is
screaming about is possible if you just
back up a bit to
you still got to go further back to the
moment before F4 this position here yeah
white can play Knight takes on D5 take a
look at that line a little crazy line to
inspect I've never I don't remember ever
seeing this tactic ever in a book Queen
F5 now and saying that the mating attack
or to H3 as well uh is Unstoppable
basically and that discover check again
by a discover check an insane idea it
turns out that after Knight takes D5
black dare not touch the dime because
you lose straight so you play the move
Knight to C6
and uh it's wild and it looks like the
tactics should be fine for black though
a little bit better for white but what
kind of position is this wow well I I
tell you I wouldn't want this with black
at all I would I would really want to
steer away from this and she did play it
it looks like
she did play that incredible move
he died she played it she found I I mean
I've never seen this time I recall
seeing this kind of idea because this
this formation normally doesn't happen
the bishop being able to take on 8-7 and
deflecting the bishop with a sacrifice I
mean of course we've seen deflecting
sacrifices before but handing the H Pawn
followed by the rep this is amazing yeah
well this is a great move to play in
time pressures that husky really is
showing her skills if she plays this
well she might be in good shape against
Irina so Bishop takes D5 let's go over
what's going on after Queen to F5 so the
idea is Maurice explained is you just
want to move your queen over to the H
file so that this bishop will be able to
back up with a discover check so just
suppose the uh The Rook moves away or
something to make some some air as well
right and then the idea would be to send
Black's King on a very short
Journey
such as this Shack
oh pardon me I did it wrong uh check
King why do you say what you did that
looked good too
yeah what about starting with Bishop G5
actually this is just as good yeah this
is this is just totally forcing it's me
right F6 and then and then
or queen G7 wasn't Bishop F6 meetings
Bishop yeah I agree Bishop whatever you
do
it indeed
20 squats squads definitely for this oh
no you can't punish her for that mate
that's gorgeous are you kidding that's a
fantastic finish so fabulous finish here
and so instead of moving that Rook over
let's try it's out it sounds like
Black's gonna have to play something
like G6 here and we've been looking at
these similar variations G7 oof remember
your Rook on my work's hanging so you
can just play Bishop takes G6 sure I'm
I'm over and if you take on G6 here then
white actually is material ahead Bishop
F6 is coming into the position and
Black's paralyzed to boot so exactly
this looks completely indefensible wow
is sinking into a deep think after this
move Knight takes D5 obviously did not
see it uh pretty impressive for santoski
and look she's only used four minutes
and Bishop takes D5 she's gonna go down
now that's that's not Hawaii Five Queen
F5 is a is an automatic here anna will
not be spending too much time to defend
this position on this move and Knight C6
actually was self-evident taking now and
allowing this queen to land on F5 just
seems hyper dangerous Knight C6 was
another move just going down a pawn but
it was hard for her to accept that
situation but she should have played 96
this I don't see where how she gonna
survive Bishop takes and queen takes on
Queen to F5
the king is just going nowhere I mean
nowhere
she might have to shift her Rook all the
way somehow the computer the engine is
giving a move like Rook to d8 as best
here allowing Queen H5
and now Knight to E6 Knight to E6 Bishop
G6 check King over and then taking on F7
so maybe she doesn't get mated just uh
in danger after Bishop back and the
pieces are flooding around her King
she's in big trouble in this line the
worst part about this is that it's very
easy to play for white there's nothing
to think about you got one strategic
idea make the king and he and even
there's Rook to d8 and 96 idea is kind
of hard to see because the whole idea is
at 96 stops the bishop coming from G5
and by putting the Rook on d8 instead of
E8 you're preventing Bishop takes F7
check from actually winning The Rook on
E8 so but it's kind of a weird defense
savior to save your shirts and at least
you can hang on for a few moves those
other variations it's just
um complete I mean just completely over
and I don't even know if she'll see this
but this looks scary enough for uh black
I wow explain why the queen H7 the queen
H7 idea here doesn't work as well so
prevents the Bishop from coming to G5
and the key variations and protects G7
as well precisely the Knight on E6 is a
great defender Queen H7 check king f8
queen HH King E7 you don't have this
move Bishop G5 key move in the attack so
that's what the idea of the Knight on E6
does is covers the G7 pawn and the G5
Square as you were mentioning that was
why the computer said well give me that
pawn bishop takes F7 check King f8 this
is I I should say that this is all A
variation that we're looking at it seems
very highly forcing and from White's
point of view
did not play that and said she played
Queen B6 so she's hoping that she'll be
able to play I don't know what she
missed I mean the bishop on it on C1
guards the H6 Square so that Queen's not
coming over to athletic over a defensive
Clover instead it's just a one move
Discovery attack but how does that Queen
really help that's the question I mean
can't we just play
actually the worst worst part Jen sorry
is Rook B1 Rook B1 is actually cold
winning world war one is winning but
it's not the most obvious move on the
board getting the queen asking the queen
to find squares Rook B1 in this position
is the best move and white will win a
queen Apparently after a queen because
yeah because Queen E6 just Queen H5
threaded his Bishop exactly Queen H5 is
interrupting everything and there's no
way to slow the attack down anymore
she's in big trouble a move like Rook to
d8 allows Bishop G6 the computer by the
way is giving mate in 19.
which is not good to deal with with all
the attack well obviously the attack is
just rolling and you having the
difference here is you haven't brought
your knight to defend the G5 Square so
now we're back into those other
variations
yeah this is terrifying very typical
defensive maneuver to get your queen
into the defense but the 86 and the G6
squares are covered so it's just going
nowhere by the way guys we should jump
to the other game because it looks like
the attack fell apart in the other game
Jacobian is all over his opponent right
now there's nothing in the board that
says Linderman is going to survive well
let's see how that happened wow I mean
this just looked we were thinking that
this one would explode later in the game
because
when we left it we left it around these
parts more closed position right right
C5 rookie one C6 Queen B3 okay so what
uh VAR is thinking is that once he moves
his Rook this bishop will get back into
the game and Lenderman
just traded Knights traded Rooks
and then popped out with a move D5 wow
so takes on C5 takes on C6 all of these
moves were played and I think Linderman
has had uh an oversight in the position
I think his intention when he went for
this very forcing very concrete line was
he was thinking Knight A4 he's going to
win back this Pawn open up his bishop
and was thinking that in case of takes
he had this really nice move Bishop
takes C6 gearing snagging in exchange
but look this bishop on
on A7
reaches down into the position and even
a move like for example Queen F5
attacking the pawn I was also thinking
even about Queen H3 but Queen F5 pretty
hot I mean just very very comfortable
for verucia
takes E8 I mean clean we've got a check
Queen takes F2 King H1 now followed by
check and that's all she wrote uh
varicobian going into the finals in this
variation so instead let's see what
actually happened on the board okay
let's get what it looks like he still
hasn't played the move uh he had oh
pardon me uh we have this yes exactly
after B takes C6 Knight A4 is on the
board so this was uh Linderman's concept
he think he was he was probably thinking
How Sweet It Is Slenderman look what he
he just reacted he just jerked back and
now he's brought himself forward I think
he sees now that he is losing and he's
trying to stay as quiet as a mouse but
it's not going to help it's too late
verusia now played the move C4
C5 C4 opening up that bishop and that's
what this whole karpov line is all about
that you want to have that Bishop active
and it's now active so you were looking
at Sea takes before I was Bishop takes
C6 Queen F5 but this move might even be
an improvement on that exactly C takes
B4 was mine line Bishop takes season
better guys it's actually a lot better
this move gives black some chance so C4
or more forcing not allowing white to
win The Exchange but that was a
poisonous exchange so why is this more
defensible for white
um Linderman by the way has played Queen
takes C4 which was a bad move it turns
out all right well
Queen D2 is looking really good Queen F5
Knight G4 Queen D2 threatening I mean
clean takes F2 check rookie 53 is in the
position precisely the point here guys
I'm sorry it's impossible for these guys
to play Perfect Chess at this time
control but the challenge in such a wild
position is to just maintain yourself
and not blunder the reason why C takes
B4 was better is because it was forcing
it actually grabbed the pawn in his
hands and then all his attack was going
to work anyway the reason why this is
not as good is because he could have
played Queen C3 and stop the queen from
penetrating that's the difference he
didn't have to take this Pawn back it
just gone upon down he decided to grab
the pawn back and now he's going to be
much worse but if T takes B4 would have
said I have the pawn and you're much
worse and that's why I see E4 was not as
good he could have just stolen upon in
the attack on this side was just too
strong but again these guys are playing
at this ridiculous time pressure and
this kind of position this is craziness
that's why you it's just Anything Could
Happen still but definitely black is
better right now but not as much as if
he had captured on B4 guys thank you
Maurice and after Queen takes C4 uh uh
are we agreed that Queen D2 looks like
death and Mayhem over here is also a big
move apparently in this position
sacrificing on F2 check that line out
wow Bishop takes F2 King takes F2 I'm
assuming Queen comes down to D2 with a
check
if you drop your king back to F1 we'll
Bishop D3 is in the position Bishop D3
skewers the queen
whoops so yeah and he did it he did Play
Bishop takes F2 oops Bishop takes F2
faces and both
exactly that's two and eight seven
vicious
aren't they bam so King takes F2 let's
see and I'm thinking Queen has to come
check
King back Queen goes to check King oh
down broke down even night here oh Rook
down is killing it once he's killing
yeah so just rookie one Jack you're
saying
attacking that Bishop
and there's no way for us to connect
except for Queen takes C6
Queen takes C6 okay and then now now
you're right you're disconnecting us and
opening up that thread again of Rook
takes G2 we just can't defend the bishop
again and not to mention Queen E3 check
and the smothered mate oh yeah show us
that okay so a smothered mate how would
I do it okay I'll make a a random move
for white Bishop takes G7 Queen E3 check
this is one of my all-time favorite yeah
smothered mates you sacrifice the queen
you force this is my favorite pattern in
chess and Checkmate to the white and
this would be a fitting way to get into
the finals of the US championship
against guyakamsky
um yeah but now Lenderman thinking after
Bishop takes F2 check you can't take
that pawn by the way even in that line
yes if you back up just a couple of
moves sorry uh so the critical moment so
C4 was played Queen takes C4 Bishop
takes F2 King Texas walk us through the
line again Queen D2 check once this once
this work lands on this rank it's over
and if Queen C6 there's also a movie
you're like yes because you mentioned it
Queen e3check yeah just devastating just
Queen E3 immediately over to H1 and then
rookie one check and you're made
finished
so Bishop F1 is the only move Bishop E4
check coming oh
embarrassing so there are multiple ways
to win over in that line so instead
after Bishop takes F2 um his version
considering rejecting this and just
playing King H1 he has to
but now this Pawn is not just any pawn
not just any pawn and white black wins
upon and gets to continue his attack as
well
um very attractive move to my mind is
move like Bishop E4 getting rid of a key
Defender 94. 94 also looks very
appealing very nice all kinds of really
uh superb opportunities here for VAR
the simplest maybe a simple getting a
queen into the fryer Queen D2 with
rookie one check uh on the horizon the
white is just for any yes
added version immediately made his reply
he's immediately played Queen to D2
check bam and then Letterman did play
King to G1 and now we're expecting this
attack guys he's interested he doesn't
see the move rookie too because there's
so much to analyze he's partly looking
at Queen E3 check he's looking at lines
with 94. and you know what I think he
might have missed the Mover key too and
how powerful it is interpolating that
move you know because there's a lot to
look at there's also rookie one check to
look at it's okay he looked at all those
more forcing moves missing the I can't
quite call it a quiet mode
well huge rookie two is on the board wow
rookie two check and now Lenderman it's
sinking in that this was not one of I
don't think this was in history of
variations not at all but I'll tell you
something H1 ever since I was a kid
playing chess the idea of doubling
Brooks on the seventh or doubling major
pieces on the seventh were was always
high on my list of priorities when I'm
on the attack and a move like rookie 2
would have been you know played in a
bullet game instantly I wouldn't even
thought about it you wouldn't have
thought about the checks or the queen E3
no I've just gotten rookie too I just
think that's my explanation for why um
London played accepted it because yeah
because this is not hard to calculate
once you see the move right exactly
Queen's hc6 and 94 just dominating I'm
sure 94 or by the way I'm sure 94 is a
winning move I I take a look yeah I take
a look at that Defender and I just trade
off when I'm on the attack I just trade
off my opponent's defending pieces a
good defending Peter so you get rid of
that bishop and now you're threatening
checkmates Galore it's just all over
the plan was to play Bishop takes C6
because that's what happened wow we
haven't moved from Perugia that's the
last one the last piece deserting its
King right to the king side look at
those pieces on the queen side hovering
away leaving deserting their King in the
moment of danger of death it's over I
mean this position is but why not Queen
E3 and and uh and queen F2 isn't that
just simple it's not just win with ease
you have lots of things happening after
work takes H2 you like Rook H2 at least
likes Queen E3 check I like Queen e3j
Queen F2 you just sit right in the face
I didn't do anything uh let me just put
Maurice's uh variation on the board
because it is truly forcing check this
out Queen takes that H2 Checkmate in our
position would be Queen age four to
defend it
or queen takes
Queen H4 but Queen H4
um and then before after that and then
just 94 threatening now Queen G2 and
then we're playing Queen H3 reason the
queen of three check is crushing VAR is
absolutely certain he's winning do we
need to find from black until we agree
five six right but so many Knight to E4
it looks like yeah 94. instead
and your your move Jen Rook takes H2
that looks like a stone cold winner too
um
94. well it just looks so so good and
again that uh smother Checkmate Mother
Day is on oh well not exactly exactly
now because at the end of the variation
by the way guys this bar looked very
happy with this busted you should go to
the other game where another king side
attack is going on and she's played a
magical move A4 look at that move A4 she
knows does white that Black's King has
only one way to run and that's that fa
square and she's putting upon A4 on the
board so that her Bishop can go to A3
and it looks like we're going to see
another mating attack happen on the
other board that's right in fact so we
we saw the position after Queen to B6
yeah so remember and Maurice was
suggesting the movie one which looked
really good instead I want to played
another move again there's multiple good
moves in this position just like in our
other game and I played Queen to H3 and
now a Tata coming to the defense with 96
we mentioned that was a key Defender
um Anna getting her King out of the way
because 96 is actually check King H1 now
Rook d8 making some air against Bishop
F5 and just Queen H7 mate and now the
move A4
trying to bring that Bishop into the P
into the game on A3 and black played
Knight to f8 and here we go I can't
believe it I can't believe it this move
A4 has allowed black the time to put a
knight on f8 and what did your friend uh
Ben Larson say a night on that face you
can't get mated right she is now winning
white is now worse there's no attack
that works
from this position because the bit the
Knight is guarding the position you're
gonna have to trade your dark Square
Bishop off for that Knight if you want
to have any attack going but Black's
gonna have time to save herself so if we
check so say we check on uh the problem
is so if we check on F5 and then you
play King G8 and then we play Bishop A3
the problem is you can just play like
Knight D7 or something no the bishop is
left queen eight six The Bishop's gone
now the queen will come over to defend
the king and there's no mating attack
yeah Queens just you can't put your
Bishop on that diagonal Queen 86 and
where's the attack and you only have one
Pawn for the attack so sure timing was
off she needed to play that move Rook B1
earlier to get this attack going instead
she played this maneuver and with A4 too
late and now she's worse in fact she's
losing she's just she's just losing now
has been played King G8 in response Rook
to be one
um on his idea
Rook B1 instead of Bishop A3 yeah
attacking Black's Queen the oops excuse
me attacking Black's Queen the bishop of
course on F5 defends The Rook so the
queen has to move let's say we're going
to pick a square we'll pick Queen C6
Queen A6 you're heading a rook on
exactly Queen A6 has already been played
in the game all right Queen A6 picking
up a Tempo Against The Rook pretty much
forcing what Anna's intention was Bishop
A3 Maurice mentioned the stone cold
defense Queen bridge to the other side
now though after after she realizes that
the Knight is coming to D7 maybe she's
gonna play Bishop G5 instead and look at
Bishop E6 guys if black plays Bishop E6
that light Square Bishop leaves the
board and you're in big trouble no more
checkmates on H7 after a trade of
Bishops true enough to bring the Knight
out just Bishop E6 trade off those guys
the attack is dead pure and simple why
are these guys laughing we may have to
have ah let's see what's going on are we
yeah
looks like a letterman might be about to
resign here
let's let's move over to lender
manukovian okay I'll bring that up on my
board right now oops got it wrong sorry
last time we looked at it it looked like
wow Carnage
84 Knight E4 was played and Bishop D4 uh
repeated moves
oh a Cobian doesn't have to a Cobian has
mate but he's repeating moves he doesn't
have to find the mate he could just
repeat moves and draw and go on as Chan
as Challenger uh for the title
that's hilarious that would be crazy
that would be crazy if he just drew the
game he can just play Rook takes H2 the
game's over right it takes H2 The Mating
attack is way too strong but all he has
to do is just keep repeating moves and
he's in and I think he knows that
Linderman knows that and there's no risk
to drawing the game but will he do it or
will he find he did take on H2 he's
going for the win kudos to him
that's right although I have to say I
think if Linderman just uh put his hand
out and said draw in this position you
just take it and take the extra 15
minutes of rest against gotta remember
this game of course is not rated it's an
armagedding game withdrawal odds
um just uh but it's kind of it's
considered rude to do that to for
Lenderman to offer a draw because it's
totally pointless yeah true very rude
you know he might as well just resign if
he thinks he's completely lost right how
does he defend Knight G3 mate right now
right you're looking at Knight G3 mate
Queen G2 and Rook H1 mate uh mates
Galore just as a chess player it's it's
maybe you feel a little sick inside to
take the draw and I mean come on this is
just amazing right right but on the
other hand you know I've always felt
that your job in this situation is to
just qualify and move on to the finals
so had uh VAR just made that uh
repetition
I wouldn't have criticized them at all I
would just said okay that's right very
proud that's all you need to do he has a
tough task against him he had to play
this nerve-wracking game with black you
know winning draw winner draw and now he
has to play gotta kamski who's a
fantastic Raptor player because the
ladies game is going to go on a little
bit longer he's going to have a little
bit more rest and time right because you
want to coordinate the start of the next
matches exactly and so we actually got a
question about that there will be a
15-minute break after the last
Armageddon game finishes until we start
the rapid matches so for instance if the
women's game lasts another 10-15 minutes
version would have a full half hour
which is where you have to play his
rapid match look at look at Linderman
you saw quite a few faces he just pulled
he is now resigning himself to the fact
that he will not have a chance to play
for the title he looks dejected uh he do
you could see that's that way he just
flicked his hands is just obvious
resignation he knows it's over his
championship dreams have gone up in
smoke in a very bad game for him with
the white pieces this is just finished
but he did give us a great run he showed
great fighting spirit in this tournament
winning three out of the first five
games then losing to only the bounce
back and win two unfortunately for him
it looks like the Finish Line Is Here
amazing tournament by Alexander
Lenderman a lot of his fans in Brooklyn
and all across the country in world now
he's picked up a lot of new fans in this
tournament when I said who do you think
is going to win I had so many people say
Linderman or his you know online handle
Monash he is
explained to me it's amazing has
occurred Bishop G1
I think we I think we saw that final and
the game is over
yes we played Checkmate on the board
thank you Alexander Lenderman giving us
a pretty made on the board a Kobe in
advances to play gotta camps gate and
what were the final moves Jen it was uh
Bishop to G1 well after Bishop to D4 I
mean oh after um
Queen C2 Queen C2
Rook H1 check Bishop G1 Knight G3 and
Knight takes G3 is Checkmate the king
cannot move anywhere because of Black's
Queen Checkmate and virus in the Cobian
will be in the finals
of our exciting game in this rapid game
looks like is going to join him because
she is just shut the whole attack down
she's just a piece up against her
opponent and they're almost even on the
clock as a matter of fact there's no
attack anymore it is gone in Smoke
I know had a clean Victory and that well
maybe it wasn't clean it wasn't easy
let's not put it that way it was
definitely tricky but she played a
couple of natural moves and she's no
longer winning guys but she's gonna have
to fight what about trying her over here
just she's got to try something well so
let's try bringing our Rook over to age
four and I'm guessing that Rook D6 to
try her best to pursue some kind of
attack but it sure doesn't look um
instead she's played the move Bishop to
F6 so she's trying to figure out some
kind of traffic trying to knock squares
trying to mix it up with Bishops
that night on f8 is just such a
wonderful defensive uh unit after Bishop
takes Queen takes Bishop takes that five
five chords right she could play moves
like Queen E6 and this Knight by the way
can defend in all kinds of ways either
on the G6 squares or on the E6 oh it's
not even clear to me that you can't just
take that Bishop I mean take take yep
it is dangerous taking is dangerous no
you're gonna have to defend the ideas
you're gonna have to defend the F6 Pawn
in order to get to H6 so I don't see
what's what the idea is here well she
has Rook D6 at some point uh in the
position or even her going to be her
Rook can take on B7 as well okay takes
B7 so it's too dangerous but damn it
doesn't look like it's enough here for
Anna instead uh tactiv didn't take on F6
instead she just played Queen to E6
right Queen G5 Knight G6 and similar
position except she actually didn't take
the bishop but guess what it looks like
The Bishop's virtually trapped I mean it
can go to d8 but then the E5 Pawn hangs
as well and the Knight comes into the
position with an actual check on the
bishop right well guys the move F4 is
playable here even losing the bishop
apparently there's a potential counter
play for for white here after F4
there'll be some calculation that needs
to be done so Knight G6 F4 takes an F6
and now so you're threatening F5 can't
do that Rook takes on D7 in that
position
oh no because of the cheat don't stop
there's a maid on the back range there's
a maid on the back range one we need one
so you got to be 20 push-ups
in that position it's a playoffs man
the blinds have been risen blinds have
been raised mine's gone up yes exactly
considerably and Anna you know okay
she's running if you can't do it she did
not play F4 and she did she played Rook
to D6
now
well I will take the queen oh okay
yeah okay so you're getting a little bit
too much there okay Rook D6 but wait a
minute there is an alert on the back
rank Queen A2 could come with it it does
come with the tempo against the rook and
that has been played quickly so now um
and then Anna quickly played Rook on B
to D1 right and now
um what's on his threat well I'm
thinking she's hoping for Bishop takes
uh G7 followed by Rook takes G6 and just
praying to the gods that something lands
Big Time against blacks Anna is actually
playing some of the computer's top moves
she's playing the best tries right now
and her her moves are very complex that
you have to find the defenses in this
position it's not so easy to just win
that Bishop it looks like she's
desperate of course she's desperate but
she's actually finding the moves that
cause the most trouble you have to find
good moves to save yourself here very
interesting so um is Ricky I guess Rook
d8 might be one of her ideas but then
afterwardier you could just play
her last move though was inaccurate
putting the Rook on D1 because because
she should have put it on G1 and save
her back rank which looks
counter-intuitive if I may just bring
that line up on my board memories
if let's Okay so in this line here it
turns out that her last move was
inaccurate she needed to put a rook on
G1 the reason why I will be shown in a
moment this capture followed by Pawn
takes looks like there's a bind but
suddenly this move Queen F2 and the move
Rook E1 is on tap as a threat so she
doesn't get to do anything at all she
can't play for for Queen H6 she lost
this move will eventually lose her
attempo and force a trade she might have
to play a move like H3 and allow this
check to happen and now the position has
changed considerably against her after
takes takes King up and there's even a
queen trade here where she'll be up two
pieces I know there's a pin on the back
row but we know that's not going to last
very long after the king moves sooner or
later there'll be an untangling on this
side and she's going to lose so it looks
like her move Rook D1 is inaccurate very
natural move though if Tate finds the
sequence she will be winning for sure
but she hasn't moved as yet now down to
under 11 minutes and Counting
so a tough situation but if if
Tata finds this movie the player with
black abrahamian finds the sequence
takes on F6 with the pawn and then play
Queen F2 she will be the contender for
the title
it will it will not even be hard it will
be very easy
wow
nice nice nice so that was why Rook G1
was key and again you can't fault Anna
because you know your natural
inclination is to keep your pieces as
active as possible when you're on the
attacks but this Tempo rookie one is key
yeah yeah Rook do you want is obviously
a very difficult move to find so now
Queenie one and rookie won brutal
threats Rook D1 doesn't help now because
just rookie won again oh there's a check
on the background well then you could
develop your knight instead if now Rook
G1 Knight develops
we've got a clear idea and after rookie
one we've got this check is really
pretty because now after King age seven
yeah well I actually wanted play I
wanted to play Rick AJ tech for fun but
also a very nice line if you take with
the Knight we've got the mate on G7
Queen H5 is much more prosaic yes and
King takes Queen H6 Queen G7 finally
getting into that G7 square but as you
point out
um Knight is six now what's wrong with
Queen H4 guys just Queen H4 and trade
Queens no no question I I was just
thinking after Knight D7 in case of Rook
D7 now rookie one is just uh crushing
and meanwhile if Queen h69 takes off six
getting rid of the defending Pawn which
was your only prayer exactly so
unfortunately it seems like there's a
couple ways there for black but a quick
question if you take and she has
captured the bishop can white recapture
with a rook know she is captured with a
pawn not to analyze and now this move
Queen
no no it says Queen E2 instead Queen oh
sorry she's starting
you so still carrying the thread of
Queen E1 check but doesn't guard the H4
square like you did in your previous
variation no longer uh Queen H4 so uh
Queen E2 how about now
so Queen F2 more accurate just
protecting that square at all costs and
now it turns out she must find Queen F2
to stay winning in the position
he's winning still because she's looking
forward
she finds that the game is over there's
no more attack she's winning because
Queen F2 actually just threatens Queen
H4 check because there was actually a
weakness and how H5 Queen H4 check
anyway trading the Queens yeah that's
what we're always trying to do when
we've got on the defense when we're on
the defense trade Queens game over
absolutely so critical moment protective
abrahamian she's despite the fact that
she had a really tough position she's
played um really really well very
quickly yeah and by the way that in this
situation she has two moves she has
Queen F2 and she has Knight D7
everything else loses everything else so
she has to find it's night of course
Queen F2 is not that hard to find but
according to the computer everything
else loses those two moves queen of two
we play in a Flash certainly so it's an
easy moment for her should be but if she
tries something else she's going to lose
or at least be losing in the position
well how is Knight D7 though and she's
found it Queen F2 and she did play Queen
F2 not a surprise I mean just to seems
like in Rapid she is pretty good at
calculating
and she's proving it today
wow that's gotta have Anna red right now
that moves says sorry your attack is
dead Black's up two nights two nights
four sometimes and the F6 square but uh
the the big problem for white is Queen
H4 check is trading Queens rookie one
check is trading Rooks
oh from Black's point of view yeah for
for Anna
I think Anna knows it now guys
the difference was before like Queen F2
at least when we played Queen H6 uh
Queen H4 wasn't coming with a check so
kind of you you stop the back rack mate
but you've created another problem
another check if you will yeah uh quick
I was wondering if she played Brooklyn
six to D4 I was about to say how about
Brooklyn and then a quick Knight D7 by
Tata of abrahamian
a quick Knight D7 wow okay so she could
take the Knight then yeah oh and I think
she's going to have to by the way take
the night and how many people
exactly allow the trade
and now after Rook takes B7 how easy is
this I don't say it's easy at all so
Tata wanted to get a position where
she's safe she played Safety First I was
not the best move Knight to D7 she's
been aggressive and played rookie one
check anyway but she's decided to play
this move Knight to D7 giving back a
whole piece in this position she will
have a winning position but it looks
like
did not take on D7 instead she just
played age five
and now rookie one check has been played
so Knight
d71 check King H2 on the board wow but
now
whoa this is getting married now it work
takes D1 work takes D1 Queen H4 check
again but afterward takes D1 instead I'm
sure Adam's gonna play Pawn takes G6
or how about this in this line by the
way Anna's kept her h-bomb and she does
have ideas of King H3 G4 G5 G6 well I'm
just trying to counterpunch and keep
this game going but she's losing a rook
guys Queen G1 check and Rook takes Rook
is a rook and let's see here we've got
so Rook D1 H5 uh checked so just squeeze
you on and let's say I'm not sure I'm
where I'm supposed to put my king but
let's say I put my king on G and just
Rook takes and there's no checkmate at
all because Black's King just dances in
France as its way to the king queen side
yeah that is the last thing after Pawn
just after Pawn takes F7 check just King
F7 Queen G7 checking E6 and just run run
for the hills and and did see that
because she has played Queen to do on
Jack so no doubt having calculated that
King G3 Rook takes D1 on the board
figuring out you know she still has six
minutes left and she she's really
rationing her time well here because you
know it's pretty scary to see those
pawns coming at you and she's like I'm
good right so after Queen G1 check what
have we seen King G3 King G3 Rook takes
D1 H takes G6 and now um Queenie one
instead of your remover takes D4 we have
Queen E1 Check Yes and guess what I
think she has a Perpetual in the
position as well ah right so she's just
gonna do that yeah right in her case I
think she will because I mean cobium was
made in two and tata's case
why not just take the draw and get to
that final and and she's going for it
she's winning easily with this we should
check and take the Rook but she knows
the droids all she needs no errors
possible what moves have been made after
Queenie one check clearly King G3
Queenie one Jack and this is a very
practical decision because it is a
little bit Messier and even just
calculating your king coming to E6 right
it makes no sense when you have zero
percent risk with this yeah it's on his
face there guys yeah realization it's
sinking in that her chance at her fifth
title has evaporated as well and she's
just allowing the repetition of moves
nothing she can do about it and now
she's congratulated her opponent wow
right and they are friends you can see
that the finale here was a little bit
different than the Irena crush on as a
toss game finale you're right respect uh
on a light their their friends use
witching I think I'm sure she's wishing
God to good luck in her final game
tattoo of wow I thought she played
really impressively under pressure rapid
no lie that she won that death match and
that Anna herself said that she thought
that the chances were even and not only
that she thought the detective chances
against Grandmaster Iran across in the
finals were better she actually no well
she said that her chances were better
than her own or something like that she
said good chances good chances but for
sure however we want exactly but Anna
will be disappointed with herself
because she really came out of that
opening with a huge huge attack and I
thought she was going to win it
and let's take a look at how it's going
to shake out in the U.S Chess
Championship we've got a game 25 with
five second increment between perugent
and gatacanski so the five second
increment honestly these games are going
to be a tiny bit shorter than these
right because 45 minute and 30 minutes
even with no increment these games will
actually be shorter right so that will
be a two-day match so both players get a
hit with colors
hit with white and it hit with black and
then in the women we've got the same
situation Irina Crush playing against
katev avrahamian and they are going to
uh Play One game with one one can move
back and odds are one of those matches
is going to be displayed and we're gonna
see another arm again just like that wow
so we may have two champions in two
hours or more likely we may have one
more playoff and yeah even increases so
stay with us this is going to be a
pretty exciting Maurice how do you think
it's going to shake out well I gave my
commitment and I was 50 I got the win
that I expected uh for the Jacobian I
thought he would have great Chances with
the black pieces but Anna my guess
slipped up the same thing with you yes
you gave two draws and we we were 50
that's what the experts are about
combining our guesses and we're we're
good this next matchup though is going
to be tremendous I believe that Irina
Crush sitting on the side both players
as a matter of fact they're Champions
they've they've been here before I would
guess that Arena Crush should go through
in this matchup although I do admit Tata
have looked loose and free and played
really well to defend herself in that
crazy position that she was in
tremendous danger I still think the
five-time champ should move on it'd be
epic if she if she lost and we had a new
Champion first time in eight years the
other matchup
verucian played so well but you've gotta
like gotta komsky I mean the way he is
so solid right now it's hard to imagine
him losing he's the only player in the
entire competition who has not lost a
single game to date that is on the men's
side of course in Reading across your
side she didn't lose any games but on
the men's side Chomsky looks like he
doesn't plan to lose any games period
verusian might have to hope that he gets
black in the Armageddon game in order to
draw and move and win the title but but
between that and now are two key games
he's going to have to survive against
gotta komsky is going to be a really
epic match
all right and we are going to take a
quick break and we're going to be back
with more from the US chess
championships as we move on to playoffs
I think it's going to be pretty tight I
think that gotta camps use a favorite I
also think questions a favorite but I
think that that game will actually be
closer because I was really impressed by
tata's handling of the clock in this
game I thought it was phenomenally good
and she looks hungry
out there for her first title but
irina's clock handling has left
something to be desired so the stronger
player but the worst clack Handler right
we'll see how it goes
foreign
thank you
hello and welcome back to the 2014 US
chess championships playoff rounds we
are going to check out the drawing of
the colors remember we have now a game
25 plus five second increment rapid
match between gotta can't scan varusian
accordion and Irena crash facing off
against Tate abrahamian who will get
white first let's take it over to Tony
Rich at the St Louis chess club
hello everyone and welcome back to the
playoffs for the 2014 U.S championship
in 2014 U.S Women's Championship I'm
here with our four competitors in the US
Women's Championship field we have tatev
abrahamian who just secured her place in
the second round of the playoffs by a
draw against Anna satonski in the first
round and we have defending U.S women's
champion Irina Crush that will be her
opponent on the U.S Championship side we
have Grandmaster version of Cobian who
just defeated uh Grandmaster Alex
Lenderman to secure his place in round
two of the playoffs and he'll be facing
off against defending Champion gotta
kamski
in order to determine who will play
which color to begin we will have a very
scientific method here one black pawn in
one hand one white Pawn in the other and
the players have to guess which one is
the white Pawn the time control for
these two rapid games is game in 25
minutes with a five second increment
meaning that each player gains an
additional five seconds after they
complete every move
joining me is our chief Arbiter Carol
jurecki who has one black pawn and one
white Pawn
and in the U.S Championship uh defending
Champion gotta kamski will pick upon any
pawn
sneaky
this one okay gotta kamski will have the
black pieces in the first round
and on the Women's Championship side
Grand Master Irina crush and defending
Women's Champion will choose
wisely
and she chose the white pieces so in
this uh first round of the second stage
of the playoffs gotta kamski will be
playing off against varuznakobian with
the black pieces and in the Women's
Championship Irina Crush will have the
white pieces against tatev abrahamian
the gains will begin momentarily so stay
tuned
oh
so Irina Crush getting white in her
first game of this playoff match how
about you I always felt in a two-game
playoff match I want white in the second
game I kind of like to start with black
and know if I have to win as white so
slight advantage to being I think it
makes more I think that makes logical
sense but I'm not sure if in reality it
happens that way because sometimes the
confidence and the momentum with getting
a great position with white and being
able to make your moves quicker perhaps
right can actually help the white player
okay but in your experience what would
you prefer
logically I prefer the white in the
second game but emotionally I prefer the
white in the first game okay so am I an
emotional person
you'll have to ask questions Maurice
will be our tie breaker in any case we
do know that Arena does have white
Maurice what's your thoughts
I think I'd rather have black in the
first game myself because it puts so
much pressure on my opponent immediately
to win with the white pieces I think
that it looks like garakomsky ditch was
black in fact so so I think it's a big
test for the player with white to have
to win the game they know if they don't
win then they're going to face a raging
storm coming at them with the black
pieces
but right now it may not even matter
what the personal preference is I think
it's going to be all about good chess
quick chest intuitive chests more
experience who cracks Under Pressure you
see got akomski there just kind of went
into a meditation pose to get calm to
get ready Peruvian just came off a very
tough exciting game has he cleared his
mind and now playing once again for the
U.S title he played in 2003 against
Alexander shabalov a game that if he had
won he would have been the U.S champ is
now 11 years later and he's finally
found his chance again at 30 years old
after having such a clear chance at 19
who would have guessed that it would
have taken him this long to get back a
shot at being the champion and he's
going to have to take down a four-time
champion one of the top players in the
world in godakonski absolutely I've
always felt by the way that gotta was
one of the best players in the world at
rapid chess he's really really impressed
me with a skill in this particular
discipline uh 25 minutes on the clock
five second increments and the players
are getting on their game faces
that's right and we do have people
watching across the street I mean
actually right next door Masters we
appreciate all of you watching from home
we have gotten a lot of comments coming
in the hashtag U.S Testaments keep them
coming don't have as much time as usual
to go through all of them but we enjoy
all you guys uh chiming in uh I gotta
say I really like goddess chances and I
think that kanski is a heavy favorite I
would put it about two to one maybe even
more right maybe maybe like 70 he's been
here so much experience counts so much
in these events and these moments where
you've got to control your emotions and
vars flying high also flying low after
winning four games on the Trot it looked
like the championship was in his grasp
Sam Shanklin up ended that dream but
here he is he's he's at the board and
he's got a chance to win the national
championship as Marie said first time in
11 years against the much more variants
world-class renowned player gotta kamski
meanwhile the ladies I think that Irene
is only a slight favorite I think I I
really almost
not the two to one definitely not two to
one right I mean other people might
disagree though maybe she's found her
form uh you know she has it is very
different the dynamic of Rapid chess and
regular chess and just because you got a
time pressure and regular chest doesn't
mean she will unwrap it as well now look
at this we have another name a repeat of
the game between Anna and Tatia remember
Irina said earlier that she wouldn't
actually be watching the game that you
would of course her coach would watch
the game but that she wouldn't be
watching it in the regular time control
in this tournament Irina Crush played
Black against octave and that was an
exciting draw Irena on the black side of
Sicilian so another principled opening
here help me out Jen we do have the
nimzo Indian but they haven't caught up
to get up to the games on uh before E3
occurred so this is a it should be
rubensteinstein just a former main line
um abrahamian has castled Bishop D3 on
the board yep D5 Knight F3 so there's
also playing with Knight G2 as possible
I really chose a more classical Knight
F3 C5 occurred and now after castles
Knight C6 yep cd5 ed5 and D take C5 okay
going for an ice cream position and uh
this is definitely Irina Crush it's
bread and butter um she excels in
playing with these types of positions
she loves playing against the isolated
queen palm position that Tatia knows
that and she likes having the initiative
with black
yes to
tati is uh she's probably gonna get a
worse position in this game but is she
going to get ahead in time is Irina
going to crack Under Pressure because he
has been cracking under pressure a lot
of this tournament I mean she had a
dominant position against me which was
one of her when her the U.S Women's
Championship she had a lot of other
great opportunities Alyssa malikina she
could have won that game exactly exactly
Victoria knee and so on and so on I had
a lot of players have missed their
chances in this event now meanwhile the
opening in godakanski version of kobian
leaves no surprises we still got a
campski play The Dutch in a must-win
situation well not must win but it would
be nice if I won situation yeah right
and in the regular dying and draw
because winning that game would have
left the destiny in his own hands and
said he got a kind of terrible position
he did in fact his way to a draw he did
it he did indeed so instead he plays his
old favorite the Asics love exactly
let's see how that happened in the game
between VAR and gotta D4 D5 C4 C6
got a back to form with the slav at the
time you would essayed the Dutch by the
way he felt that he absolutely had to
win with black knight C3 Knight F6
Knight F3 A6 now VAR was certainly
expecting goddess Choice played G3
captures on C4 95 immediately going for
the recapture of the pawn B5
is a dangerous option for white after
Bishop G2 attacking the pawn on C6
that's why we didn't see that we did not
see the move B5 by gotta instead after
Knight G5 I believe he played G6 is that
correct or we up to date after the
movement no
we should talk a little bit about the
prize money as well what are these guys
playing for besides the title which is
all important now one funny thing is
that first players will not be split the
winner of the US Championship will get
45k okay winner of the Women's
Championship will get 20K okay but
second and third are split oh really and
the reason for that is that a lot of
times it's just a tie and there's no
playoff at all so kind of silly to split
those on tie break I see so you know it
would be complicated to write into the
rules that if there's a playoff they're
split if it's not there isn't so
basically what that means is that these
games are even higher Stakes than you
would imagine actually the difference
between first and second is going to be
20K for the US championships 45k for the
winner 25k for the loser okay big swing
and the women's is going to be 20 20
compared to 11k a nine thousand dollar
swing that's right wow you're pretty
good at math
normally I'm looking at squares okay so
after the move G7 G6 gen if you could
bring me up to date what moves were
played did we see Bishop G2 by VAR let
me uh let me take a quick look at that
for you
um and yes we have seen uh so after G6
you say yes we have Knight takes C4 on
the board okay Bishop to G7 right Bishop
G2 yep Bishop E6 Bishop E6 uh touching
the Knight a little tickle Queen D3
perhaps yeah a very standard move and
then castles castles no nothing yet
nothing yet so a little bit on the
slower side for a rapid game I suppose
so we can expect Castle castles yes and
Maurice what do you think about this
opening who do you like it for
I think it's a great situation for white
uh to be sure in that game because it's
it's Rich it's interesting and it's
something that varusian wants in order
to win I wanted to just pull up this
position however In This Moment here
after Bishop to G4 in a very classic
position Crush played the move Knight A4
quickly
making a point it's kind of an odd move
bringing it right over to the side
making sure this trade was not possible
in C3 defending this pawn and thinking
about the move A3 tickling this bishop
and it looks like she could win this
bishop if she wants to Queen E7 was
played so if she attacks this bishop she
could get the advantage of the two
Bishops whether or not that would be
anything at all in this position
especially considering Black's Dynamic
possibilities the fact that black is
well developed these pieces are still
not in the game may not mean that much
she could also just avoid everything and
play a move like B3 and get her Bishop
to this Square what she does know is
this Knight will be able to take that
pawn and that she won't be doubled on
the Square so she played that very fast
very quickly you've got to think that
she had this prepared she knew this
position because she played it quite
comfortably but now this move Queen E7
has landed on the board and now she's
stopping to think for some time maybe
this one has surprised her and she's
looking for a way to get an advantage
guys
thank you Maurice uh interesting move
Knight A4 because uh standard stuff
there is like A3 Bishop c5b B4 so a
little bit of a wrinkle by arena in this
game and I would expect her to continue
with the move A3
uh back to and what do you think about
that after oh sure let me bring that up
on my screen
I also pardon me I also like to play
against the isolated Queen Pawn in my
career so I would go with what uh
Maurice was saying that I would go after
this dark Square Bishop A3 Bishop takes
C5 Knight takes C5 B4 oop Queen takes C5
B4 I'm gonna win a free piece there yes
do you like playing with the trampoline
and you also like
I do it it has a little chigorean s kind
of situation where white gets two
Bishops black gets two knights and free
play here what I'm looking forward to
trying to do is play Bishop B2 black
should probably go out of her way to
stop this Bishop from on B2 from Bishop
on C1 from developing to D2 with Knight
C4 I think black will be fine here one
of the things that white likes to do is
go King H1 and Rook G1 and it's easier
to play for because I feel that maybe
the plan for white is a little bit more
clear but at the same time the night
sometimes leads for easier playing in
these types of positions yeah it's just
toss-up it's a toss-up it's a battle of
Chess ideas I like the Bishops uh but if
the knights get really secured outposts
like in this particular case the Knight
on C4 looks really really that crush is
really good with two Bishops though I
feel that I kind of gotta like that is
that a force line for takev does she has
a chance to play for instance uh Queen
C3 Rook V1 and 95 immediately yeah it's
kind of like the same pretty much
transposed well you're giving me a
choice I may I may not otherwise have in
this particular move order you're giving
me an opportunity to play Bishop B2
Queen takes D3 Bishop takes E5 we've got
Bishops of opposite colors but again
it's about that isolated Pawn position
hard to say
unpleasant for white yeah a little bit
balanced but okay but if you were to
play Knight E5 immediate I don't think
it really changes matters I would
probably drop back with my Bishop
challenging you to take my knight on F3
and then just uh capture her on F3 yeah
well this is this is kind of like a
dream position for white if she can ever
get to her Bishop on this long diagonal
and dominate from either the D4 square
or just putting pressure on this long
diagonal right and we don't we don't
come in time with 94 because it's just
Bishop to B2 Bishop B2 I always have to
be careful about that lurking night for
but Bishop B2 is a Tempo and then this
Queen by the way might travel over here
and you got to worry about uh
checkmating threats against the G7 Pawn
but definitely I'm thinking A3 was
Arena's idea and having said a I expect
her to follow up with A3 A3 yeah okay
guys I should also we should note the
stylistic differences between the two
players
is a very tactical player Arena crush
doesn't mind going into tactics but
that's not her forte she's a positional
player she likes to be solid she likes
to shoot from strength tatv is Wilder
you saw how she handles the crazy
position that she got when she had to
defend against Anna zotonski she'll find
the tactic she'll be intuitive she hates
defending she hates being in torturous
positions so she sees that isolated Pawn
position and thinks I'm going to have to
hold this for 45 moves she will despise
it she'll start looking for variations
to cook up the game to make it
interesting make it exciting and that
may not be anywhere in the cards in this
position because right now she's been
attacked A3 attacking her Bishop what
else can she do she has to take on C5 it
looks like I mean is there another line
I mean she maybe she's thinking about
taking on F3 but the point is
this position has only really one solid
move to play that that I can see and if
she just does what she needs to do and
takes the pawn on C5 then she will have
just played with the position and not
put it away several minutes so it's
taking her some time here to decide on
what looks like really the only move in
the position and I think it's because
her personality leans towards aggression
and not towards having to defend exactly
and that's a problem problem with
playing against one D4 I mean if you
don't like playing the king's Indian and
the closest positions that result from
that it's not that easy to get the type
of position that abrahamian likes which
is you've got to go to uh deepen the uh
chess history books some of the dustier
variations of Blumenfeld Gambit for
example benkos Gambit and mix it up that
way but she doesn't have a position
that allows her to express her tactical
inclination and
shook her head like she's a bad game
you'll be like
Pawn let's trade I defend isolated Pawn
100 times it will be draw even if you
win this Pawn I make draw but she's like
agitated right now look at her
calculating lines that are simply not
there and probably will have to take on
C5 at the end anyway
and my goodness I don't believe
instead she played Bishop to A5 that's
incredible what a decision you called it
Maurice he decided that she was going to
sacrifice upon keep as many pieces in
the position as possible but boy what a
big decision maybe that's why she's
shaking her hand because she regretted
it right after playing it
there's no real Attack here that's a
free Pawn she just gave she has gambited
upon with no real pluses in the position
to speak of to avoid a slightly worse
end game this has to be a bad decision
on her part and I'm sure Irene is
thinking yes thank you now it's time for
me to just consolidate a position and
you will not have any attack to speak of
so from drugs to pawn eyes here at the
championship something like that but you
know before we all uh jump on her and
say that's a horrifying decision I have
seen players incredibly resourceful
players Grandmaster Larry Christensen
comes to mind and he doesn't mind giving
up uh material if he got moves like
Knight E4 and Rook on A8 to d8 in the
position he would say
um to me hey your knight is on A4 way
out of the game uh I got an opportunity
to go crazy on the king side and yeah I
won a lot of games with Larry I mean he
won a lot of games against me as well
and so it's a danger just double edged
very interesting point I mean remember
it is a rapid game and only five second
increment you can't you can't really
Bank off of that no so 20 minutes now
it's 20 minutes for each player nobody's
arguing whether or not it's a good move
but she made a decision that she thought
was practical and she's gonna have to
live with it absolutely I mean it's kind
of like I think that it was a 10 minute
game we would totally
be okay with our decision but 20 makes
it feel like oh that's a little bit more
time yeah white will find some really
good defensive moves and just
consolidate her material 20 minutes as
you think it is I say I mean we saw
those minutes fly by in the championship
right the second time to draw was just
like blinking we're back to playing on
the increment and this is very different
because of course the increment being
five seconds instead of 30 seconds
irina's gonna have to really play
quickly and make sure that active
doesn't uh get an initiative and cause
her to falter how are we doing in the
other game yes
we'll go back to our uh
situation neither size is castle that's
a bit of a surprise after the move Queen
D3 Bishop E6 uh attacking the Knight on
C4 Queen D3 defending the Knight and
then I gotta immediately played the move
Knight D5
um his idea is that he's opening up his
Bishop on uh G7 that lies in Ambush to
the pawn on D4 and he's threatening
knight uh B4 in this moment when the
queen needs to stay on D3 to protect the
Knight but cannot okay so after Knight
D5 what we saw was Knight takes D5
Bishop takes D5 and we're in this
position hold on
uh there's a little bit of a problem in
the position for Gada first of all
Bishop takes G2 is a big and if we play
Bishop takes D5 Queen takes D5 there's a
double attack against The Rook on H1 as
well as against the pawn on D4 and I'm
just wondering has VAR fallen into a
trap early in the opening he has played
the move Bishop takes D5 and now gotta
kamski to play and queen takes D5
wow okay uh there as some form of
compensation there is a B6 square a weak
B6 Square so for example after castles
Queen takes D4 God got him uh pardon me
avar may be thinking that okay I can
play Bishop E3 and Knight B6 uh I've got
a threat as well but that's not
what VAR wants we know vars is an
incredibly solid player he doesn't like
sacrificing pawns early but like this
doesn't this look at
that easy right because if you
can Bishop E3 idea yes exactly and that
looks pretty strong and if you don't
castle and you play like Knight D7 then
we can play Rook D1 and Sack on D7 right
so maybe this is not so bad like so you
want to show that after sure C2 for
instance yeah so Queen takes Queen back
here yeah 97 Rook D1 and what gen you
you're suggesting is that well maybe
after a move like Queen
G4 you could you you were thinking C4
now actually protects the D7 square but
we can still consider playing Rook takes
D7 but then a lot of pieces are coming
off the board and you're simply at the
ending up uh not upon if we if we take
on A8 but not so fast there is this nice
little move Bishop E3 it's not like The
Rook is going anywhere for the moment so
two surprising Pawn sacrifices in both
of our U.S Championship Playoff games a
Cobian sacrificing a pawn and Tata and
his black sacrificing upon so the
challengers are they over excited from
their Armageddon playoffs well we do
have Grandmaster Robert has paying us a
visit from Lester's and he's with
Maurice Ashley to answer those questions
with Grandmaster Robert Hess who's doing
commentary over at Lester's how those uh
barbecued spicy barbecue chicken wings
going for you I think there are barbecue
chicken wings today because you asked
for them yesterday they didn't want to
bring them out for you oh they probably
ran out of them everybody found out
about them well Robert these games are
hot the last two games we saw were
really interesting games mistakes of
course but still it's rapid chess so
that's what happens uh this one what are
your opinion first of all uh what's your
opinion of this particular game for both
sides yeah I think out of the opening
black got the advantage not to say on
position I mean I think black is
slightly better here but I think just
because of komsky's style he plays this
C6 A6 G6 every time he faces one D4
except a couple rounds ago when he
played VAR and tried to win and got a
really bad position but just the kind of
the structure the position favors komsky
for sure and now there's already some
clear weaknesses the pawn D4 uh if black
picks that up and can keep it then white
might be in some trouble do you think
that the compensation that uh you saw
Yaz and gen analyzing with Queen well
after castles uh then Queen takes D4
Queen C2 Bishop E3 and Knight B6 might
be some comfort for white yeah
definitely some conversation a move like
B5 well it looks kind of strange there's
no light Square Bishop so B5 it actually
attacks the Knight you have to move it
immediately and maybe black can unravel
with starting with a move like this I
think realistically white has very good
chance to regain that pawn but even if
you recapture a lot of Trades will
happen it likely fizzle out into a draw
so I think compsey's playing no risk
chess right now which is great for him
oh but he took with the pawn on D5 it
looks like but still I think black is
has no complaints in the opening
absolutely no problem here symmetrical
Pawn structure to be sure a knight
coming to C6 it looks like he has a
better Bishop as well looks like komsky
won't lose this position if this game is
a draw do you think for sure comskey
wins the match
yeah I have to like confidence channels
I mean the guy was World rapid Champion
a couple times this is a rapid match
he's experienced he's very strong and
you know he has to be a bit confident I
mean he won his last round game against
friedel a really tough game by the way
but you know after that it's it's hard
to really knock his chances all right
let's go to the next game between Irina
crush and Tata abrahamian and a pawn
sack right out of the opening with the
black pieces you're shaking your head
you don't like it no I think two games
in a row tottenham's got himself in some
huge trouble with black I mean her first
game is honest she was probably just
completely lost except for incorrect
move order on honest part
um and then Taja was winning immediately
so
um some shaky play from Tata but here
it's really not so clear it's a dynamic
position I haven't seen how much time
each player has but uh I mean I guess
well these times are correct so 15 20
for white looks like Irina Crush
starting to think yeah that she's under
some pressure clearly the black pieces
are amassing trying to attack yeah and
it's always a problem with 9984 as we
saw you know in many games determined
just from last round Lenderman against
Jacobian already the positions in
trouble but the Knight got an A4 the
bishop B2 there can be some issues but a
White's position is very nice here and
if white doesn't make any you know kind
of critical mistakes I think what has
good chances to take home the point I
don't like the move that was just played
though in B5 that weakens the queen side
tremendously so you know actually tatv
you know she can play well here and
definitely survive I think you think
she's that this was a bluff though in
her part to play like this oh I don't
think she did on purpose I think like
she got in the position she knew it a
bit and then I mean it really made
national move A3 B4 and she's down a
pawn I think that yes there is very good
compensation and I don't think she's too
unhappy with her position but it wasn't
some deep preparation of sacrificing a
pawn so
um yeah maybe just nerves if she were to
draw this game do you think this would
be such a tremendous achievement for her
that she will have a chance to win the
championship more likely than not with
the white pieces yeah she down is a good
chance I mean if we saw in the
tournament uh she almost beat crushed
with white she had great winning chances
certain points
um Chris is there a 30 move draw rule
here
but uh no back to your question
realistically if she does hold this and
has whitened the next game you know
Irina admittedly is not the best uh
rapid player she admits herself every
time I get some time trouble you know I
I she said in her interviews in the past
I get up all these pieces and I blow
them all away and we've seen that at
this event yesterday against Victoria
she had a really dominating position
kind of threw it away and it was almost
lost and was lost a certain point
against melakina she was winning you
know in the position got time trouble
blundered so you know Tata is actually a
pretty good Blitz player and Irina is
too rapid and Blitz player but as the
times dwindle down you have to favor
tata's chances if she can hold this game
and get the white pieces next game I
think she actually might have the better
chances between him too well thanks
Grandmaster Robert Hess with those
insights we let you go back to Lester's
and you'll find those barbecue chicken
wings man bring some more I'll eat them
all before you get them indeed all right
guys uh it's on we're right in the
midpoint of this critical Championship
these critical Championship matches
some interesting there from Grandmaster
Robert Hess those of you who haven't
visited the St Louis chess club in
person you better do it soon we've got a
good excuse for you coming up with
sinkfield cup exactly oh well that will
be the game the event of the year and
certainly the event of the United States
oh yeah although this has been the most
exciting Championship I've ever seen and
I've played in a lot of them that I'll
I'll I'll agree uh with you right away
no question yeah I've been in a lot wow
this is a and we have seen by the way
this recapture
quite surprising compensation was too
brutal exactly he he he he thought about
it for a considerable length of time he
did recapture with the pawn attacking
the night the night jumped back into the
center of the board with Knight E5 got
into play
I'm sure he's very happy about this
bishop uh lurking on this long diagonal
he's a groom fell player uh he likes
such positions and now he has to decide
Knight C6 or Knight D7
yeah it was actually a fairly critical
choice if he had gone for night C6
then the difference is that after the
trade he'll always have this lever C6 C5
to open up the diagonal after playing
Knight to diesel always if we don't end
up occupying the C5 square right that's
the key I mean he takes some risks with
the move Knight C6 because if white is
able to control C5 white will be better
well after Knight D7 going for the draw
this is how they draw with black
followed by wind with white right here
black has absolutely nothing to complain
about in fact black is actually slightly
better right that Bishop on D4 I mean on
D4 wishful thinking
prettier than the one on C1 exactly and
in fact we have a couple more moves
Castle Queen B5
immediately since seeing if there's an
end game maybe we don't even need to
Castle right so Knight D7 Knight takes
season seven Queen takes D7 castles for
white I see Queen B5 now for black so
offering a queen trade
with the idea that those double pawns
won't be a big deal because they're
rough on the A8 Square will be exerting
some nice pressure on A2 so I especially
with the combination that if you ever
play A3 maybe we can play B4 ourselves
so far we should actually decline the
invitation to double those pawns and
played rifted Elon I see what do you
think about that decision I mean if
Queen takes B5 how do you how do you
rate that position after Pawn takes B5
and now we're do you I guess Rook D1
Rook A4 was coming in the position as
well so you're just gonna uh I'll accept
that I will have a a slightly inferior
uh Bishop on D2 now rookie okay so Rook
A4 so your move Bishop D2 the idea is
that um after we play something like
Rook A4 and Rook A8 you're able to play
A3 and then B4 I can play Bishop takes
B4 exactly right 64 is no longer on the
menu exactly so here I I thought this
would be a draw frankly I don't see
um any reasons that that after for
example a move like Bishop C3 that white
shouldn't you know I mean black can try
keep trying to do things but it's very
very hard these double pawns are not
great in terms of opening up the queen
side so I thought that that was a a
rather interesting decision that a
Cobian did not double the pawns instead
he did play the move Rook D1
so I would anticipate after Queen takes
Rook takes King D7 we're going to see a
similar in the ending without these
double pawns
and again a very balanced position I see
a lot of even more balance yeah I see a
lot of Trades coming down the C file if
you will so probably the next game in
this match is going to be more exciting
I'll put my wager on that
yes yes
uh this has not moved the hearts and
minds of the American public
you know is going to now have to defend
with black and that's not gonna be
pretty if this game does indeed end in a
draw exactly so godakamski will kind of
take the psychological edge here in this
map if he draws that first game with
black meanwhile we are going to see some
fireworks eventually in this Irena crash
over Hobby in game indeed you know just
a couple of minutes ago we were I mean
not a couple of minutes ago but just a
few moves ago when tatv made this
decision to play and sacrifice her Pawn
that was only four moves ago but already
we've got down to 13 minutes so it was
20 minutes and now we're down to 13
minutes and that's why I think that it's
like we said we didn't like tata's
decision because there were 20 minutes
on the clock but suddenly there's 13 and
now what do you think well yeah I mean
the clock is a is a vital uh part of the
game of course I was just thinking in
terms of the position on the board uh
Tasha played this nice
uh move Rook E8 but that that nice move
rookie eight I think really
um isn't the best and I would have
jumped with the Knight to E4 right away
uh Robert Hess when he came on he didn't
like uh irina's move beef beef 4b5 but I
thought that that was a an excellent
move after Knight A5 Queen C2 was played
Bishop coming back to uh B8 we can see
that
um black is preparing a move like Queen
C7 to put pressure on you know creating
a battery Arena to play well actually
Arena has played Bishop dvd4 but I was
trying to bolster that pawn on C5 well
not only that just putting the bishop in
the middle of the board stopping any
kind of dynamic
sacrifices based on D5 D4 and preparing
to
reroute her Knight back over here to the
king side and really
um so that C5 would then be protected so
you would call this move Bishop D4 it's
kind of like over protecting the phone I
love that I I I I know I like the idea
of just getting the bishop in front of
the Knight so when we bring our Knight
back to C3 the bishop on D4 yeah it
protects the pawn but also
um just blockades actually on the D4
Square as well as attacks the pawn on G7
I really like this play by Arena and she
does have about 13 minutes Tata is now
on move and kicking down to 11 at wow
this game is going to be a really
intense as I said before the time
control is actually shorter than the
Armageddon game right so here a crucial
decision for tatiel uh should she play
Queen C7 and provoke the move G3 she is
of course threatening to play Bishop
takes F3 he's really the only choice G3
right so now some light squares over
here on the king side weakened or does
she say G2 G3 is actually helpful for my
opponent but let me put my knight on e4
uh right away and just perhaps stop your
your plan of playing Knight to C3 as
well
well I don't know if it stops the plan
of Knight C3 so much as just puts the
Knight on a good square and leaves the
eight you know the queen could
potentially go to H4 instead of
committing herself to C7 so for the
moment you won't be able to play nice E3
right because of Knight takes C5 yeah I
mean and then uh there's no real
trickies
I have Rook 65. something that that
night on C5 so that I kind of like your
move 94 because of that right I mean
although I guess you could play Queen C7
in conjunction with Knight E4 you could
play both of them exactly so that and
you know maybe that's what that was
considering here but hey you know she
has played 94. yes what do you think
Marie is how do you think of Tattoo's uh
compensation here
well active pieces are active pieces so
you know me I've I'm used to sacking
upon for compensation this kind of Pawn
I don't really like I didn't really
appreciate that sacrifice I think it was
a little bit too wild but in a rapid
game anything can happen especially if
you play quickly I think Arenas could
handle itself quite well staying
composed this position Knight to E4 uh
is definitely a strong move
still you know that you play the
isolated Pawn position but only when
you're even in material so even playing
it when you have the even material for
example this Pawn not existing on this
Square even that's still hard for black
to prove anything
when it's even in material down upon two
how can this Pawn be a bad thing for
white kind of hard to believe that will
be bad it has to be a plus even with all
this activity here this night will
return to C3 quite soon you're right
right now it's not possible but soon
enough there's going to be a rook move
uh well now she's played the move Knight
to B2 so there she goes circulating her
Knight to this side of the board that's
going to be a problem and forget we've
been talking about this night on A4 what
about that night on A5 I mean it's not
much better so we can almost eliminate
these two guys in terms of power except
this one can't get in the game either
and now it definitely can't get in the
game so I think that White's just better
here I like white even if she's not on
the attack yet I think she's going to
consolidate it's not necessarily by much
yet but I think that this will be a very
difficult position for tatif to prove
herself guys
I agree and Knight B2 I thought Arena
was going to play Rook on a to C1 and
then Knight C3 but Knight B2 uh
preparing to play Knight D3
going over to the king side to cover up
her uh
to further bolster her defenses that
looks like a very solid Choice by Arena
I was just instead of playing between C7
Tata is playing a move which looks for a
longer term Queen potential and she's
like Queen E6 with the idea of rerouting
the queen to H6 air okay well uh clearly
uh
Irina had prepared the move Knight D3 so
let's see let's imagine that she were to
play it and then doctor continues with
her own plan and plays Queen to H6 right
now again with the thread that Bishop
takes F3 and inducing uh G3 right but
now because the Knight is already on D3
you start to think can I jump into the
center where the move light Knight E5
with a double attack against that Bishop
on G4 if trades which is what white
wants white wants to reduce uh Black's
attacking potential Knight comes to C4
the move like F2 F4 and White's still
upon up and Black's attack on the king
side very hard for black to break
through all of these uh
defenses if you will in